基本上我觉得这一周跟上一周市场观点没有什么特别大的变化
我就不再去质述上一周我讲的那些事情
上一周我简单总结一下吧 上一周我是觉得
其实现在市场在一个相对的争空时间
就是争空时间意味着我可能缺少一些货币侦测
至少我缺少货币侦测延续性嘛
就是你哪怕12月份降了息对吧
你后面连续降息可能现在没有很大手上没有特别多子弹
那个退税就是共和党的退税政策
包括我的财政政策那起效也是需要时间的
就是货币政策退税政策然后一直到明年3月份的时候
那个业绩也没有爆出来
就是我们现在就比较说上周看到了因为非常好的业绩
但是这个业绩可能你得等三个月再能看到一个
你看到其他MACA7的你可能要等两个月对吧
因为有业绩有限有后面有一些可能要等两个月
所以现在市场就相对来说比较争空没有calculus
没有那个没有催化级
那空头就会比较多大家就会准备去做空
其实这段我是周末准备星期已经涨到头宫脑花
但我觉得anyway吧这个还是有可能会跌回去的
就是这么快的上涨其实Vol很大上涨并不是特别健康的吧
那么如果在周末错过或周五没有买
然后周末错过我今天不用急啊
就是接下去是会有机会的
那Binsan我们再一个争空器确实是有争空器
但是明年我觉得市场会涨到大家头宫脑花
就是现在AI上面我认为
那我这个我好几次视频讲过很多次我就不坠述的是
AI中间其实并没有什么bubble没有什么泡沫
为什么呢现在其实公司用的都是自己的资产负责表在头
串联中心然后ROE投资回报率都非常高
包括公司其实大部分的这些你看到涨了很凶的公司
都是业绩在推动包括AI中间的末尾最差的meta
他现在都要去用Google的tpu了
那个他其实也是业绩在推动
所以我没有觉得AI中间有很大的泡沫
相反另外一边的需求非常非常旺盛
然后供货严重不足
那这这个事我觉得明年推动市场一个很大的
就是AI事我是觉得很长扭的
不是长扭吧
就是现在还没开始有泡沫
明年会有一个比较大的泡沫
这个原因我也说了
就是这些政策消失之后会回来
然后我今天会早中说一下货币政策
然后早中说一下12月份那个fat decision
其实12月份我个人觉得并没有那么的重要
我是觉得他会降息的
然后但是最好情况是他不降
然后always的不降
而不是hocus的降
就是不是很银派的降息
而是鸽派的不降息
这是我个人的看法
但是我觉得没有那么重要
那本质上对于连储的政策
就是连储贯穿明年他会做什么样的政策
货币政策会怎么样
这个我今天可能早中说一下
然后也会带到一下
因为现在市场讨论的非常多的
现在市场讨论很多的
就是英伟达
英伟达出的业界很好
然后谷歌谷歌很抢风头
对吧
和jmr3很牛
谷歌我之前就一直说他很牛
然后这个就是两个阵营
他最后会怎么去选
会怎么样
就是openai的阵营和谷歌的阵营
然后最后这个事情会怎么样
然后其他一些影响市场因素
包括中国和美国的贸易战
然后昨天市场长很多的是
说西主席要可能会防美
然后台湾普又可能要防滑
对吧
这个是在四月份的时候
那个trump自己啪了
那个true social在说这个事情
然后这个可能是
最后我会提一下
比特币就是BTC的这个情况
然后先说一下
早中说一下货币政策
我觉得用一句话去概括
我认为明年的货币政策会怎么样的
是the train has left the station
这个车已经离开火车站
也就是他踏实岸一条不归路
这个意味着不管明年谁是Fat Chairman
然后不管Fat里面
现在在12月份这次决定的时候
有多少descent
你可以看一下前两天市场
跌的时候的这个状态
就是市场的高点
是不是正好在上一次降息结束
然后上次降息完了以后
大家认为上次降息结束
这一次是我们叫做鹰派降息
降息完了以后相对发言比较鹰派
然后不光是降息会后的比较鹰派
而且连处不少人跳出来
就是对于12月份的降息提出了质疑
今年本来一直说
我说是两次
两次后的三次
然后现在我还是比较倾向于三次
但是你提出质疑之后
大家就觉得可能我这边不会降息了
然后那当时降息概率被打到了30%
其实降息被打到30%的时候
上周我其实没有讲
这个cladroless lending rate
你可以看在10月30号的时候
那个cladroless lending rate和那个interest rate的
中间的差别有多大
就是这个代表银行的流动向
就cladroless lending是我银行手上持有权
然后去接待
然后拿银行信用去接待
就代表银行间的流动性
变得相对来说比较长
但这个是相对来说比较短期的
月底的一个调整
但是后面又有积极夫妇好几次
其实市场像一个小孩一样
会不停地教育你
就是你不给他奶喝
他就会哭
然后他会叫
叫到你没有办法
所以市场一开始叫完就开始跌
然后连处就开始上周五的时候
Williams出来说
连Williams是没连处纽约的主席
所以他的话语相对来说
比较其他的连处要连处的成员会压更重一点
而且他的jpeg的关系跟相对比较close
更近
然后他出来说的意思
就是12月份还是要叫
然后你不要叫有奶喝
那是这个态度
其实市场就为什么说train has left the station
就是我其实不管明年会不会有大概多少的通胀
其实通胀不会特别严重
会有多少通胀
然后我不管连处里面有多大的分歧
然后基本上明年的货币政策的大走势
大趋势就是送
因为会很送
然后他没手上没有弹药降息
他会想出其他的办法
提供其他流动性的扩表
我现在就不是坚定的流了
我现在是非常怀疑
或者我觉得很有可能连处会推出各种各样的
就是扩表的政策
因为手上其实弹药用完了
我直接降息的弹药用完
我之前讲过没连处
你们不要期望他明天可以加三次四次系
把他利息降了很低
然后变成zero interest rate
这可能性非常低
因为我们现在的通胀还没有很低
我们看一下通胀
我们现在的通胀
这个是高盛的预期
就是我们本来的通胀是应该是条红颜色的
显然
然后没有tariff的
但是现在有了tariff
增加大概百分之
百分之零点五
拱门预期是零点五
53个business point
其实就是百分之零点五的这样的一个通胀
所以使得现在通胀率在百分之三
上下是二点九年底可能是二点九
按照高盛的预期可能二点八
但 doesn't matter
这个会比
你不可能把实际利率降到负的
现在你股票走到快到歐滩派了
这个反弹完以后又要去歐滩派
又要到最高点去了
然后你怎么可能让利息变负的呢
所以连处手上是其实是没有弹药的
但没有弹药
你要面临的另外一个情况
就是其实美国就业情况不好
这个我们抛开股市涨了很多
抛开这些大的
大的科技公司业绩的黄豪
我们上次也讲到叫KShape
我们回顾一下我们上次的KShape
KShape意思就是百分之
就是扬吃人的股市
也就是说百分之一的人获利
然后百分之九十九的人被吸掉
这就是AI发展
或者是新的生产力革命的本质
我要淘汰旧有生产力
而且大部分人都在旧有生产力
这个中间包括你们所有专业的人
包括外保险的人
包括医生 律师 会计师
等等都是要被淘汰
在这个过程里面
就是AI的生产力一定是淘汰
而且是比较先淘汰掉学生
college student
这个是people with bachelor degree
你可以看到
Labor market for college graduate
就是对大学毕业生在美国会变差了
现在状态跟2008年差不多
比2008年稍微好那么一点
你不能跟疫情的时候比较
那个时候大家都失业对吧
但是你正常的情况下
现在是非常差
就是那个对于大学文科毕业非常差
也就是你可以理解到
为什么美国大学生都想回归共产主义
都要做共产主义接班
因为他们都无产阶级了
那个手上背了student loan出来找不到工作
那他不想去搞互产阶级采贯
他没找还没搞革命
然后但是这中间的变化
就是AI会取代很多人的工作
那你想另外一边美联储在决定
我是有通胀
还是我面对就业的时候
他十次里面会有十次去选就业
就业永远是美联储
最最核心的一个考验标准
我们现在不能光看
比方说我们新的能放配若
我记得让想想看
好像是要到PCE
新的PC要到9月份的PC要到12月5号出来
忘了能放是能放在10月份的
能放配若是什么时候
但是我们看到比方说
从你这些数据即使出来的话
也是真空的
就他数据的质量都很差
因为政府在关门
但是你可以看到比方说ADP
明天要公布ADP
明天公布ADP
然后包括接下去的
initial jobless claim
你可以看上去可能他没有那么差
但是这些数据都是lagging indicator
就是一个制后的数据
公司一般会先停止招人
然后再会砍人
然后这些人失业才会去file jobless claim
所以你可以看到公司招人的情况
就是layoff tracker
在20现在这段时间上升得已经很快
这个是相对来说
这也不是现行
这个是现行的
也不是先行的
不是像consumer trust index
或者不是像consumer confidence index
或PMI这种事
相当于先行的调查指数
它是现在我的layoff有多少
然后这些数字会优先于initial jobless claim
这些已经失业经人数
会优先于非能就业
会优先于这些数据
会优先于失业率
所以我们可以看到失业率不会好的
就是我对于美国一季度的经济数据
我是比较悲观
这个是往后看12个月
就是12个月的预期
其实大家现在把12个月之后的预期
慢慢调高了
但是你可以看3月份的时候
其实3月份就预期到明年3月份
那那个时候大家都觉得
可能是在一季度的数据最差
其实大部分的观点对于一季度的时候
都相当于是在谷底
你是不是说像财政部长Bassent说
我们美国2016年是不会衰退
我觉得即使不会衰退
也不会差太远
就是这个数据是会比较难看
所以在数据真空的同时
可能会有些数据不是特别好的
两个经济数据基本面的数据会出来
那么为什么说
The train has left the station
就是就业是这么一个状况
就业是这么一个状况
AI革命又是要隔掉很多人的就业和饭碗
在这个里面
其实美联储没有什么选择
就是他要去支持一场回归
Private sector driven economy的过程
就是共和党现在要做的事情
你现在别管Trump
会不会因为Apps and File给搞掉
我觉得Lightly不太会
他很有能耐
然后他就算被搞掉也是Vance
然后基本上现在共和党
要做一件事情叫回归Private sector driven
因什么意思
就是以前Biden administration的时候
他用的财政支出是很多师傅之情的
比方说给到疫情的时候给每个人发钱
然后相当于是支出型的救助疫情支助
然后医疗设保
然后短期的一些自己这些东西
然后但是BBB法案中间
原来还有什么清洁能源这些东西
但是在BBB法案中间
他其实测中几个
一个是Infance Sharks的投入
就是基础设施的建设
包括光带网络交通这些东西
然后另外一方面
他其实是退税
就退税是把钱还给老百姓
然后把那个
就是一个是走社会
叫什么
民主社会主义模式
一个是走比较坚定的
原始自文主义模式
当然是后者对经济影响是更好的
就是作为一个市场参与人
你肯定是不希望
这个国家变成一个社会主义国家的
面北欧这种
它是不会有任何火力的
那个Government政府的消费
Government tax coming from somewhere
这钱肯定是从哪里来的
那个Government政府是没有钱的
这个Sacha分说到
这政府是没有钱的
except for tax money
那这钱都从语秘说来
然后它redistribute重新分配
就一定是不公正
或者是无效
那么它其实美联储接下去
要支持的共和党的一个
一个我们叫做转型
是要回归到Private Saturation
不是Public Saturation
即使它是有赤字
但是它希望是退税
那么这个中间的
是需要经济经过很大的调整
而且加上有AI
它是有很多人会失业的
那连处它必须要扩表
就是必须要采取
比较宽松的货币政策
对于他们来说
现在难处就是
我想这样写
我当然想把利息降到网站
但是问题
就是那问题
你搞了个tariff
把我的这个CPI弄到
就是那个把PCE搞了很高
所以我现在NATV interest rate
我没有办法做
这个也是为什么在6月份的时候
我觉得CSLR这些公布
就是其实大家在下棋
都是把下面一步想好的
你你并不是说
他我现在手上没有牌了
到时候我就死翘翘了
他们其实也是想好
这个牌出牌的顺序
我手上牌的
按照了什么规律怎么出的
那个SLR和ESLR的这个规管
放松可能给银行增加两千亿的capital
然后在一年的时间
你们可能会慢慢释放出来
就是从8月份完成领寻
8月好像底八二十几号完成领寻
然后你算6个月到8个月
其实基本上8月就是11、11、11、12月份
然后在2月份到4月份
就2月份到4月份
其实联储是可以通过
让private sector的银行
就私人部门的银行
让你们扩展资产负代表
因为过去2008年的时候
把你们手脚都给绑上了
然后那个时候是过程当中是不停的放水
然后来平衡你们把你们手脚绑上
现在我不能放水
就不能降漆了
所以我就把你们手脚打开
让你们去往市场上投放的东西
这个是一种
然后甚至明年
我觉得美联储还是会采取
各种气息关关 扩表乱的
市场是一个美乃河叫的小儿
在本身经济在转型
本身就业情况很差的时候
其实连储的容错没有那么的高
他不是要看着美国的股票
但是他必须得看着这些东西
必须得看着这些东西
就是他的就业情况
然后但是股票可能不会涨
不会带来就业
股票涨也还把那个就业
把工作都给弄我们都没了对吧
但是股票跌必然会把就业变更差
所以他现在处于很两岸的一个状态
没法降
他就会想出各种各样的办法去
各种办法办法去那个
Ease in Financial Condition
所以市场在教育那个
Edebite有两种可能会造成
要么就是就业差连处
想办法去扩张资产负代表
要么就是市场流动性很差
然后通过Financial Stress
就是这个市场的这样这种
市场的那个流动性的一些问题
然后被迫让他去放出的东西
其实美联储
我就说美联储说是独立的
从来都不会是独立的
他们不是act on an agenda
他们是act on the best interest of the United States
那是为美国的利益服务
为国家利益的服务
那就是他需要去平衡
同仗和增长
但是在增长和同仗中间
他一定会去选增长
然后那个
所以我对美联储明年的政策
就是货币上的政策
你不要看他降不了多少戏
甚至我觉得美国国债利率
不会下来太多
因为我们有很多的国债性的供应
但是整个市场流动性会太差
就是流动性
现在你要去观察
他有很多指标
你不能只看TG1
能看Reverse Report
然后看College Last Vending Rate
这个东西
跟College Last Vending Rate
是一个Mixer
是一个
怎么说呢
就是这个东西
像医生看病人的各种方面指数一样
他并不是看一个
你就能够知道他怎么样
其实你要 overall 整体来看
就是这个
这个晚点
我专门出一期说
怎么去看这东西
但是市场一旦不好
流动性就会惩罚美联储
然后让他去做这个行动
所以Anyway 讲了15分钟
我觉得basically
我的歪年就是
对于美联储的政策
你们不要去期望在12月份
就一定降
12月份我觉得大开率是会降的
因为他的经济数据是在12月16号出来
12月18号出通胀数据
这两数据都没出来的时候
12月10号你敢不降吗
不一定敢
不降 市场马上辞给你看
然后但是对市场最好
当然是他不降
不降
然后他表示我后面要降
这个是可能对市场最好
然后要反弹 要蒙涨
然后这个不重要
重要的是
他明年肯定是以松为主的一个政策
而且不光是美国
现在你可以看到德国的经济数据
日本经济数据出来都不好
那你家中国就不用输了
中国就一塌糊涂
其实大家都要印钱
别人就是大家consensus都要印钱
所以明年呢
从货币上
从政策上
然后从财政政策上和那个
大家的这个动机上
就是都是放水满多的一年
就是我觉得社会出现泡沫的一年
所以你在现在这种情况下
每过三个月就质疑一次AI
AI现在的这个状态和科技股泡沫的时候
完全是不一样
科技股泡沫是没有人质疑的
那个时候都觉得我们公有革命
我们终于又来一次公有革命
现在AI也是公有革命
但是那个时候
确实没有那么多人不停地去质疑泡沫
长到你头宫眼花
但是AI的每过三个月来质疑一次
你可以看到
每一段时间去质疑
比方说英伟达或者是整个AI这个产业的人
他说的比方说
CAPEX的问题
CAPEX可不可以持续
CAPEX可不可以持续到RY
其实从2024年
2024年讲的问题和现在
你看回头看有区别吗
没有任何的区别
这一轮的质疑和2024年年初的质疑是一模样
特别那一次是2024年
我记得很清楚
7月份的时候的质疑声音是非常强的
这个质疑和现在几乎没有区别
所以我觉得AI的质疑不用特别的强
那说一下
我这里没有画图
我说一下这个市场的spectrum
那个acquity to smell a position上来看
我记得我大概在一个月前说
我说可能调整
但是不可能是像4月份这种
这种大规模的调整
这个是为什么
因为4月份的时候
大部分看到市场投存非常非常拥挤
你这个不光是看acquity对吧
然后你看到那个wall control strategy
就是那个wall control strategy
就是还有my wall那帮人
gamma position
包括你看到cds的gamma position
看到cds的position全部是一个方向
通通在多石头里挤油
那这个时候爆弹
大家是等于全是多头一起出来
但是我上次讲到
就说cds的变宽其实给了市场一些缓冲
就是有一些在cds上面
在倾性市场上面做多的人
其实在上一轮
9月份那个时候已经被挤出去了
那我们看到这一轮虽然下跌
wall最高的时候升到25了
所以这个并不是wall升到25
是很悲观
wall升到25要爆跌
不是的
因为它开始跌的时候
wall就没有很低
所以本身在wall上面去做那个
my wall
my gamma那帮人没有很多
所以gamma squeeze的效果没有那么好
没办法squeeze你
不像以前那个头寸放得很紧
很多人买option
你一下子暴涨
以后这些option全部要给你平仓
然后头上马上变成巨大NAC的gamma
现在并没有这么严重的这个情况
所以其实头寸没有那么拥挤
是这一轮我觉得跌不会像4月份
跌的这么深
很难
这是仓位的问题
跟信号没关系
信号比方说那个时候是关税的
现在可以说anything
就是你市场或者是自己可以就是空窗
然后就给你跌一把
这种这种可以
就是原因can be可以是任何东西
但是你这个东西能够跌多少
本质上是看着你这个市场上的财货
多了多少多了多少
现在市场上财货没有对很多
包括你看cta position
cta当然cta这个week
就是这个是周末的信息
大概是flat的话
那个130亿美元卖出
所以这个星期还是有很大的卖压的
那但是你看是e的位的
就是说不是像过去那样
就是说我如果涨的话
我基本上cta已经满藏了
cta没有满藏
cta现在败质相当于相对来说
比较比较双边
就是跌的时候它会卖
然后涨的时候它会买比较比较双边
所以你像这种仓位的话
就都败质上来说
我觉得可以跌的
但是你很难调到很深
就是仓位不支持你把它整体
那种暴仓性的跌
这个是我个人的看法
然后说一下供specifically的事情
然后可能不一定有时间讲比特币
然后比特币放在玩家
我比特币加5分钟多说5分钟
然后说一下英伟达和谷歌
这最近聊的比较多的
因为我一直是谷歌的坚持的看多的人
对吧
然后你们也知道
我一直在买谷歌
然后我从来没有卖出谷歌
然后我确实能看多谷歌
我在107的时候说你们买了可以睡觉
然后我说谷歌的这个算力的成本已经比
已经比OpenAI便宜了
这是挺早以前
然后最近市场开始炒这个概念
而且因为谷歌的Germany 3很牛
然后包括今天早上
Meta说他要买谷歌的TPU
所以谷歌被炒得很火
我是怎么看这个问题
我觉得谷歌和OpenAI是美国和苏联
你可以把它理解成
就是这样的一个当量的这两东西
绝对一方不可能东风压倒西方
就是东风压倒西方是不会的
另外还有个台风
台积电要配货
就是台风才是最后的这个配货
你想谷歌是真正的台积电的大买家
你想大部分的手机出货都是安卓系统的
所以其实都是谷歌
所以你要说东风压倒西方不太会
两边一的位都不会
所以现在你可以看到谷歌系的比较得益
包括明天我觉得最近这两天
好像我看阿伯给我长得也很凶
但是在OpenAI体系里面
包括你给它做TPU training的一款
比方说英伟达
我觉得是没有什么问题的
英伟达的业绩很好
而且确定性非常高
明年deliver
不外乎你买它
买不买TPU
它的确定性都很高
它一直处于缺活的状态
最最厉害的是英伟达
他说明年的margin还要再几十万
这个是我其实之前一直觉得margin要掉
就是英伟达无论如何
没办法维持这个margin
他能维持这个margin
就是这个毛利率
所以我是觉得炒冷不炒热
就是当内存你觉得很火的时候
其实不应该去炒断
应该把它卖掉
然后去不及表输光模块
在谷歌很牛的时候
谷歌是个非常好的往事
我觉得谷歌没有任何问题
如果你要长期持有的话
但是在短期里面
我个人会觉得英伟达的性价比相比的
可能会比谷歌好一点
这个是我作为一个长期一直买谷歌
从来不卖掉的真正的谷歌的信仰的人
我在短期的交易上面来说
我对英伟达很看好
就是不会OpenAI这些事
就是他不会被判掉
那整个就是你可以在
因为其实大家是最后都会赢的
输掉的是大部分人的工作
和不相信AI的人
不相信AI的投资人
这些人才会输掉
就是他们都会赢
都会赢
就谁赢了
现在早一点就去买谁就好了
然后这个差不多
然后最后说一下那个
我没有说比特币的时间
比特币电量比较多
然后其实有很大的一个原因
我觉得是Metal strategy
就是Strategy
就是MSTN
MSTN要被MSCI提出index
这个提出index
这个是最近两天已经吵了
市场上都知道了
市场上都知道那就反弹了
那个他要提出这个index
时候其实有很多的知道
10月时候可能说会提出去
然后预先
大家就会做空一波
然后真正提出去
可能发生占民意二月份
所以他的空头会一直压住
可能会提出去概率
现在觉得基本上大概6个被提出去
所以这些空头
就会预先的去埋伏
然后去去做index的这个做空
index吹的基本上就是谁得到信息
找谁赚钱
你等到index这个调整的时候
你再进去
那个强卖强卖
就没有任何艺人
那都是都是反过来走的
比方说你要被提出index的公司
你到了快被提出去的时候
真正被提出去开始蒙涨
因为空头平仓
那个都是Found Browning
所以MSTR被砸了比较凶
所以这个其实这一轮带动的比特币在下跌
那么但我其实看昨天的这个
昨天美国反弹了很多
美国反弹了百分之二年级了
那是打头反弹百分之二年级
其实下MSTR
我觉得没有反弹到
我觉得他应该反弹到位置
因为他周五的时候也没有反弹
然后他其实是周末的时候比特币
因为怕周一美国长很久
所以他们开始
就是在比特币上开始做多对冲
对冲MSTR的空舱
然后但是MSTR在日间交易的时候
我觉得反弹力度不是很大
就是我觉得可能要再看一下
MSTR手上的空舱
就shot interest是不是够多
就是是不是答应进去做多了
但是我的直观的感受是
当市场都知道的这件事情以后
他你就不用去考虑这件事情
就不用考虑这件事情
对对比特币市场的特别大的影响
所以如果说你明年是觉得
因为很多人问到比特币的问题
如果明年是觉得一个流动性相对来说
比较多的市场
当然最好的选择肯定是A
就是肯定是晚道题
但是如果是本日B权的网家的话
你觉得明年是流动性比较好的市场
我觉得比特币
你买在八万还是买在七万五
买在七万还是买在八万五
没有特别大的区别
这个是我个人的看法
就是当然当红最最当红的不是他
但是最最当红肯定是我前面讲的
A那些东西
然后最后呢
昨天市场就是有一些政治吧
昨天市场上讲到
美国可能可以给中国卖那个H200
就是半脑子芯片
这个中间有一些什么样的交换
不大清楚
那有可能跟朝鲜那边有点关系吧
但是有这个以后呢
就传出中国和美国
美国可能会合作
就是特朗普可能要防华
然后席可能要防美
那这个这个是
市场传的这个消息
但是呢
最后我视觉的中美之间
那这使得有一些票
在境外表上说
做算力中心的这些公司
跌了跌了挺胸
然后他觉得
哎
中国美国片都直接可以买给中国了
你还在外面干这个吗
我个人是感觉呢
中国和美国的蚕豆是永无修制的
就和两党之间对于这个这个BBB法案
或各方面的这个蚕豆一样
他他他他没没完没了
他很难很难这个
因为一次会议
然后和或者是什么东西的种子
其实每一次的谈好了
都是修缠
都是truth
然后继续呢
美国最近那个联邦
这个最高法院要去判阿依帕的事情
就阿依帕就是
通过阿依帕
然后来给大家加关税
然后啊
我觉得白宫现在已经开始准备
就是如何应对这件事情了
因为你可以看到
白宫其实对关税的准备
3012他都开始
section 3012都应该是看
我觉得白宫可能在prison自己
可能打出这场官司
但是完了以后呢
他其实对中国的关税
他其实不太会停
就表面上希望跟你缓和关系
但是实际上的就是
因为这个是中美之间真正的角着
就是你可以把ai想成美国科技领先
就是他知道也已经被中国完全超过了
他科技领先
他需要继续科技领先的孤注意志
所以在ai上
大家们都是all in
包括Peter Thiel
他们的看法是很简单
中国是我们最大敌人
但是我们要打败他
无所谓
我需要再知道也是麻烦你
我就是ai上科技上
把你领先一波给你清掉
然后我们现在就全部压着ai
然后把ai做起来
所以你说明年
是不是这个巨大泡沫有可能
但是明年肯定是一个大泡沫要吹起来
所以我觉得中美之间的缓和
一切都是战事的
个人的看法
这个政治就评论太多了
好吧
我今天就先说到这里
然后我们看法有什么要Q&A吗